parce que vous vous avez déjà frôlé la
mort dit ici ou bernard montiel
oui oui c'est assez violent une cabine à
uv il avait il avait demandé 40 ans que
ça me bouffe on comprit 45 jours j'ai
cramer non c'était à on avait loué un
bateau ajaccio pour faire un petit tour
est en fête avec les langues
on dira alors je vais vous dire un yacht
racing on avait loué des années y'avait
prince albert il y avait trace de lui et
tout le monde
ils sont trompés au moment de mettre de
l'essence ajaccio quand on a pris le
bateau
au lieu de mettre du diesel ils ont mis
de l'essence donc alors en fait ça
explose pas mais on est parti et d'un
coup ça s'est arrêté
donc du coup quelqu'un nos potes plus
intelligent design a été voir et ça a
explosé
on est carrément on a sauté à l'eau ont
explosé s'apprête à wes ah bah oui quoi
rien ou trompé de carburant et on n'a
pas ces problèmes au mieux des yachts
avec du personnel banon mais si vous
prenez un zodiac qui nous fait mal mais
gilles moi je suis passé alors j'ai
plusieurs sera qu'une grosse perte pour
moi et pour moi j'ai aussi mes mois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'étais petit je traverse est toujours
en courant donc je suis passé au dessus
d'une voiture est en dessous d'un camion
de livraison et j'ai disparu sous les
roues la room a frôlé les pôles et ma
mère a cru que j'étais mort elle me
courait après et le chauffeur du camion
s'est arrêté en larmes comme ça et en
fait j'ai traversé tout je me suis
retrouvé sur le trottoir d'en face et
j'ai atterri dans un magasin c'était
vraiment le cheveu isabelle on sait
qu'elle est tombée d'un éléphant oui
mais j'ai cru vraiment je suis tout le
haut du corps rentrer dans le bail
surtout je suis resté à terre mais la
différence du coût à il a eu peur il a
reculé et au moment où il m'était sa
patte sur ma tête mais non c'est pas un
secret défense
mais oui j'ai failli rester là quand il
a fallu mettre sa patte sur luis attaque
ce cas puisqu'il arrive les chutes et
souhait le cornac m'a enlevé la vitesse
et je vous aurais manquent pas dans la
rue bank
oui je vous le dis tiens un ronnie way
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
rené on est sûr d'une chose c'est que
son coiffeur est mort ça vous avez fait
vous avez failli passer aussi à 18
heures parce que un jour que j'étais
javel cézanne est un fait précis c'est
là qu'ont connues sable malaguti cyclo
marwick y aller qu'on pense que j'y sois
martine may leur mère de maruti aux
métiers des machines à marcq à tuer ou à
témoigner comme j'en avais j'avais
gonfler la cyclo marche avec 15 à leurs
jours ce même col j'ai décidé d'aller au
cinéma photo le virage juste corriger
prévient le capitaine voiture en face et
qui coupe ainsi court
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors je l'aurais fait avec le guide
la voiture regardez vous voulez qu'on
termine par une belle histoire oui il va
rattraper le coup et maxime dit oui
c'est terrible
c'était sur la côte atlantique jugé sur
mon matelas gonflable sommes d'accord
pour me promener sous leur voile sur
l'eau sauf que ceux ci ont mené par les
banques la tempête et je vois pas je
m'éloigne delà de la côte à l'est de la
côte au moment un moment je suis dit je
suis perdu j'écris de toutes mes forces
help sous les doigts personne ne l'avait
vu ma vie défiler tu me dis [ __ ] ou
célibat mais j'ai vu ma vie défiler on
peut se mettre dans l'ambiance
j'ai fait sauvez moi j'ai fait 5 à une
urgence le dos mais franchement j'ai
touché toutes mes forces
et oui ce sentiment de fatalité qui vous
arrive là dessus et là il ya un an ce
qui est arrivé non c'est un sauveteur la
trentaine il m'a repéré il m'a passé
très près de la plage et j'ai pleuré
toutes les larmes de mon corps et non
pas de bouche à bouche à toutes les
larmes de mon corps est depuis jeune âge
là où les pieds là-bas tu rêvais à bercy
[Applaudissements]